bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 société
on va s'intéresser à une réforme dont on
parle assez peu en ce moment et pourtant
tout est en train de se faire ou presque
dans les yvelines la réforme de la ddsp
autrement dit la direction
départementale de la sécurité publique
autrement dit la police pour résumer ce
lundi en comité à départementale
technique la restructuration a été
adoptée elle ne fait pas que des heureux
pour en parler en plateau loïc travers
bonsoir ils sont représentés le syndicat
alliance et puis cédric torrès du
syndicat ufap unsa devraient nous
rejoindre dans quelques instants je
rappelle que nous avions aussi convié
d'autres syndicats tels que le syndicat
des commissaires de police la cgp police
est fou encore synergies à venir il a
participé à ces discussions mais il
n'était pas disponible pour débattre
alors avant d'évoquer cette
restructuration ce qu'elle implique
surtout une explication sur ce que sont
les directions départementales de la
sécurité publique elles ont été créées
le 31 août
1993 ces directions dépendent du
ministère de l'intérieur en relation
constante avec les autres services de
l'état que sont notamment la préfecture
ou le tribunal de grande instance et le
rôle de la direction départementale de
la sécurité publique s'est déterminé
proposer des orientations de sécurité
adaptées aux réalités départementales et
puis fixe évidemment les objectifs à
atteindre alors le département des
yvelines est divisé en quatre districts
qu'elle se partagent 19 circonscriptions
là il ya le district versailles qui
comprend les circonscriptions de
sécurité publique de versailles à celle
saint cloud des zips lésions fontaine
fleurie le district d'elancourt qui
comprend les circonscriptions de
sécurité publique d'elancourt de trappes
rambouillet et guyancourt le district de
mantes-la-jolie et le district de saint
germain en laye alors il ya déjà eu une
première étape dans cette
restructuration de la police qui a été
mise en place en septembre 2013 est ce
que les lecteurs pouvaient nous
expliquait d'ailleurs cette
restructuration qui a été mise déjà en
place une première phase en septembre
2013 et puis une deuxième place qui va
donc voir le jour en septembre 2014 tout
à fait donc la première
la première phase était essentiellement
lié à des restructurations sur des
entités départementales donc c'était à
l'époque
la bac
d parce qu'on appelle la bague d la bac
départementale 78 qui a été complètement
dissoute et l'ensemble de ses
fonctionnaires ont été en fait dissous
dans différents services qui sont
aujourd'hui bas soit dans des
commissariats ou dans des agglomérations
il y avait aussi la sûreté
départementale qui a été réorganisé et
enfin il y avait la création de ce qu'on
appelait les ujap donc ce sont des
unités judiciaire de paix de proximité
qui traite le petit judiciaire donc des
petits larcins des petits vols on se
retrouve aussi sur des choses liées aux
délits routiers
voilà donc la problématique c'est que
cette bague des 10 août en fait à donner
ou plutôt enlevé de la souplesse en fait
puisque elle l'était un peu spécialisés
dans certaines missions pourquoi cette
première restructuration a eu lieu
c'était quand même pour revoir le
maillage du territoire pour certaines
équipes alors revoir le maillot le
maillage du territoire s'était
effectivement ce qui était
officiellement annoncé après l'acronyme
bac je crois fait peur à certains il
faut pas se voiler la face et
aujourd'hui effectivement un moment les
bacs dès il ya une volonté
une brigade anti criminalité à redon il
ya une vraie volonté en fait de 2,2 de
les dissoudre et pas seulement sur le
département 78 il y a plein d'autres
endroits en france où c'est le cas voilà
donc l'idée c'est que ça surtout un
petit peu enlevé un petit peu de
souplesse voilà il était spécialiste
notamment du transfert de détenu
particulièrement dangereux il était très
apprécié dans le cadre d' enquête de pj
pour des ouvertures de portes à 6 heures
du matin et maintenant aujourd'hui ce
sont les effectifs locaux où ces mêmes
collègues qui ont été un petit peu
saupoudré dans différents services qui
gère tout ça mais je crois la plus
grosse déception que nous avons ce sont
les unités judiciaire dp proximité qui
était censé être une révolution à
l'époque l'idée n'était pas mauvaise sur
le papier mais on sait aujourd'hui que
les collections asphyxiés sous les
dossiers de la proximité la proximité
judiciaire faire du petit jésus 10 hier
et pour répondre en fait à la population
à travers un accueil une écoute et un
traitement rapide des procédures et
c'est pas du tout le cas on a des
collègues et qui croule sous 160-180
procédures individuelles et donc c'est
au détriment des victimes c'est au
détriment en fait de la réponse
judiciaire qui est susceptible d'être
bien donner rapidement voilà donc c'est
à dire qu'on travaille dans l'urgence et
c5 qui quelque part aujourd'hui pour des
problèmes posent problème je rappelle
quand même les donc les quatre principes
directeurs de cette restructuration
c'est préserver le maillage territorial
et aucun commissariat qui n'a été fermé
qui sera fermée et aucun commissariat
qui a été fermée après c'est vrai la
priorité aux terrains resserrer la
chaîne de commandement et puis créer des
circonscriptions de taille suffisante
alors d'après ce qu'on peut lire
notamment dans les rapports le premier
train de réformes est dit-on positif
puisque les interpellations par exemple
progressé de 40 % + 41% des auteurs ont
été interpellés
prendre 2 % en augmentation d'affaires
élucidées dans les affaires de convoyage
des stupéfiants ça c'est des chiffres
qui sont bons oui ça prouve que la
première réforme était plutôt bien mené
vous savez les chiffres on leur fait
dire à peu près ce que l'on veut et moi
j'ai plus qu'à rembourser d'autres types
de chiffres par exemple je vais je vais
citer à poissy qui est touché de plein
fouet par cette réforme il la brigade de
sûreté urbaine bsu donc y gère deux
grosses enquêtes judiciaires un taux
d'élucidation sur l'année 2013 de près
de 58% et pourtant va la réforme est
donc on a là l'exemple type d'un système
qui fonctionne très bien qui est très
bien rodée avec des gens très motivés et
on est en train de casser le système
alors sur le terrain ses bons résultats
on les constate ou pas pas partout pas
partout il y à des endroits où les
cambriolages ont explosé on a
des explosions ont aussi deux chiffres
en matière de délinquance contre les
personnes et ça c'est un véritable
problème est quand effectivement on se
borne à mutualiser des services ou à
simplement ne pas les renforcer eh bien
on déserte la voie publique et à un
moment ça devient dangereux pour les
concitoyens mais le fait que par exemple
tous les commissariats soit conservée ça
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle oui sur
le papier c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
il faut y voir plus loin les choses
c'est à dire qu'il ya aujourd'hui des
petites structures comme la celle saint
cloud comme marly le roi comme vélizy je
vais pas toutes les citer mais qui sont
effectivement qui ils sont complètement
succès en terme d'effectif il n'a pas
assez d'accord pour tourner donc l'idée
effectivement dans ces endroits dans ces
petites structures de les aider et
pourquoi pas de les réformer on n'y est
pas tout à fait contre d'accord c'est
pas une opposition de principe comme ça
mais c'est simplement que on considère
que ça va beaucoup trop vite et qu'il ya
des endroits où on va mettre les
collègues en difficulté
je vais par exemple citer le cas de
trappes qui est susceptible de recevoir
l'ensemble des effectifs de la bsu donc
de la brigade de sûreté urbaine
d'elancourt de trappes et de guyancourt
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas où on va les
mettre ces gens et donc le projet alors
que la mise en place est prévue pour
septembre c'est de supprimer une salle
de repos ainsi que la salle de sport des
collègues et son peux pas le tolérer
canton et délégué syndical c'est
impossible et d'ailleurs je regrette et
j'aurais bien aimé entendre les harvey
en oeuvre en a régalé les yeux de mes
collègues d'unité police sur ce sujet
c'était la première vague de réformes de
m elle devrait être mise en place en
septembre 2014 tout ça a été voté hier
en comité technique départemental
donc au lieu de 19 circonscriptions
sécurité il y en aura plus que 9 tout à
fait et ça veut dire que donc il est
forcément tout sera un peu plus
resserrée donc on se dit que c'est
plutôt positif l'idée en fait de trois
pôles puisqu'on va les appeler comme ça
il ya un pôle on va dire pilotage rh
support
il faut quand même savoir que sur le
dernier comité technique qui donc s'est
déroulée hier nous avons voté pour cet
hiver qui avait quatre grands sujets
nous avons voté deux sujets qui ne
concernent que effectivement 15% des
effectifs mais nous avons voté pour des
choses qui paraissaient logiques par
contre sur la répartition liés aux
collègues qui sont sur la voie publique
ou qui gère approprié lloris et les
enquêtes judiciaires là on n'est pas
d'accord sur sur l'actuelle pour résumer
mission qui ne sera pas donc il y aura
finalement trois pôles un pôle pilotage
que vous avez dit oui analyse
opérationnelle ressources humaines
moyens un pôle voie publique tout à fait
un pôle enquête tout à fait et la ccit
sur ses sauts ce pôle que vous dites
pilotage vous convient par contre sur le
pôle voie publique et paul enquête non
ça va pas en fait ça pour ça on fait
donc du coup tous les moyens seront
vraiment revoir comprendre au niveau des
usa qu'il y en aura peu près partout
d'accord donc ça veut dire que pour les
petites choses
judiciaire il n'y aura pas de souci par
contre à partir du moment où on veut
aller chercher des enquêtes complexes ou
avec des résultats qui demande beaucoup
beaucoup d'investigations à partir du
moment où on aura des infractions graves
style des cambriolages avec une
multitude de personnes concernées des
agressions sexuelles ce genre de choses
eh bien ça nécessite des traités par la
brigade de sûreté urbaine donc un
service des enquêtes adapté avec des
spécialistes et ça y en aura partout
partout partout et ça sera plus grand
que ça veut dire que par exemple il ya
des gens de guyancourt qui devront se
déplacer à trappes pour leur dépôt de
plainte pour le suivi de la procédure
pour une confrontation donc ça veut dire
qu'à un moment par exemple sur le
service public rendu on ne s'y retrouve
pas par exemple le district d'elancourt
qui couvre trois circonscriptions de
police trappe elancourt aiguille en
cours mais ce n'est pas les vilains cd
circonscrit moyon danser sa confession
il ya également des villes mais dans ces
trois circonscriptions
comment ça va se passer demain
organisation qu'est ce que par exemple
commissariat de trappes aura comme
le commissariat de trappes va garder en
fait le support de la brigade de sûreté
urbaine qui corresponde au judiciaire
d'accord avec des unités de jour et de
nuit d'accord mais par exemple
les brigades de nuit seront pilotées
depuis elle en cours voilà donc ça veut
dire qu'en fait il n'y aura pas une
contrairement à avant une espèce
d'équité dans les services présents
localement et on craint en font en
fonction des services qui seront
affectés dans tel ou tel endroit et bien
que par exemple il y ait des délais
d'intervention parfois plus long parce
qu'en fait la circonscription à couvrir
en tout cas le territoire à couvrir sera
le même qu'avant et je vais donner un
exemple très simple en fait qui est
typique d'une mutualisation
quand vous avez une brigade à à 10
personnes une brigade b à 10 personnes
vous les réunit c'est ça fait vingt
personnes sur ce même territoire à
couvrir mais il faut savoir que la
mutualisation va consister à en retirer
cinq ou six qui vont être dispatchés
ailleurs parce que justement on a plus
d'effectifs qui arrive sur le
département 78 donc les vins se
transforme en 15 pour le même territoire
donc là je demande simplement si à
travers ce constat les concitoyens vont
s'y retrouver en termes de couverture ce
que vous dites c'est que derrière ce
principe de mutualisation des moyens qui
peut sembler assez logique finalement
alors un grand pôle enquête ou un grand
pôle voie publique c'est quand même
mieux que d'avoir des petits pôles vous
faites donc fallu une problématique on
pallie à une problématique qui essaient
de l'arrivée en masse des fonctionnaires
de police alors sur le 60 18 mais c'est
aussi vrai sur les départements voisins
et sur la grande couronne parisienne
mais est-ce que les yvelines pour être
un département qui fait un peu office
d'avant garde et il est monsieur le
directeur départemental je regrette
d'ailleurs qui est pas
non plus un représentant de la ddsp ou
de la préfecture pour nous expliquer le
bien fondé ça aurait été extrêmement
intéressant de pouvoir débattre avec eux
mais c'est évident qu'on peut parler de
départements pilotes et que notre seule
crainte aujourd'hui c'est de voir cette
restructuration s'étendre aux
départements voisins et notamment ce qui
me concerne
eh bien le 77 le 95 et le 91 voilà on a
une vraie peur et bien fait que ça serve
de modèle alors même que l'on avait
enrayé un début de problématiques à
palaiseau dans l'essonne et à bezons ou
d'ailleurs nous avions été soutenue par
le maire qui voit là et on était même
votre une intersyndicale ce qui mérite
d'être souligné
alors allez-y le gg on sait divers et
variés voilà il ya de toutes tendances
nous en avons communiqué beaucoup il y
en a que je remercie d'ailleurs au
passage pour leur soutien à la fois dans
la presse à la fois dans nos actions à
la fois par les courriers qu'ils ont pu
adresser dans les commissariats donc je
veux pas faire de politique donc je veux
pas les citer par contre nous avons été
très surpris du sommeil de certains et
je me demande comment ils vont se
réveiller à la veille de leur procès
principales échéances électorales à
venir notamment pour ceux qui sont
députés aux sénateurs j'imagine qu'à ce
moment là ils crieront loup d'un manque
d'effectifs sur leur circonscription
mais il sera trop tard il sera trop tard
donc ces rapprochements là vous ne les
comprenais pas non dans le maillage on
ne les comprend pas pour les services de
voie publique et pour certains types
d'entités judiciaire notamment ceux qui
vont gérer des enquêtes on va dire d'un
certain standing et qui mérite des
investigations lourde et aulas ou là on
a affaire à des gens expérimentés non on
ne comprend pas absolument pas la façon
dont ça a été actée alors j'ai tout à
l'heure que tous les commissariats du
département allait être conservés ça
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle nous dit
ça dépend ce qu'on met dans les
commissariats c'est à dire que pour vous
certains pourraient devenir de simples
poste de police exactement c'est à dire
que nous notre crainte aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on est en fait quelque part une
période de transition on a su rassurer
tout le monde à la fois les concitoyens
à la fois les élus qui sont à la tête
des villes et pour le coup nous savons
puisque ça s'est déjà passé par le passé
que le fait d'appauvrir un commissariat
et quelque chose de symbolique quand il
n'ya plus de commissaires à la tête d'un
commissariat de police moi j'appelle
plus à un commissariat voilà alors après
chacun s'il fait son se fait sa propre
idée mais c'est une vraie problématique
et pour les citoyens qu à votre avis
qu'est ce que ça change le consensus
moyen ce qu'il veut c'est l'air limitée
un commissaire ce qu'il a envie ce qu'il
a envie quelqu'un qui est à elancourt si
les concernés par une procédure
judiciaire est là pas envie d'aller
attraper il n'a pas envie de la guye en
cours en vigueur il faut changer les
habitudes et c'est peut-être mais dans
tel ou tel c'est pas très loin en somme
c'est pas très loin mais il ya des
endroits où c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué c'est le cas de poissy par
exemple et de conflans sainte honorine
voilà où tout va être regroupées sur
conflent et seulement certains groupes
vont être conservées à poissy voilà il
ya des endroits où une égard à la
démographie et à l'étendue du territoire
je suis très inquiet pour les collègues
qui sont restés dans ses services live
qui vont devoir gérer le quotidien
maintenant et pour vous pour vous le but
c'était quoi vais réduire les moyens de
personnel oui aujourd'hui d'avoir des
problématiques c'est que on a une règle
malfa ya des règles qui s'appliquent
dans le cadre de la réforme générale des
politiques publiques qui avait été mise
en place sous l'ancien gouvernement en
2007 et qui se poursuit depuis le 18
décembre 2012 qui part à la retraite
par exemple cessé mais c'est d'une façon
générale en fait leur gp a été remplacé
par la modernisation de l'action
publique ce qu'on appelle communément la
map est dedans en fait il y à un recueil
de textes et d'audit qui n'ont pour seul
but c'est dire à un certain nombre de
2,2 d'entités en fait étatique donc dont
la police nationale eh bien comment on
doit faire autant voire plus avec moins
de moyens financiers moins de moyens
humains et moins d'effectifs c'est
simplement ça la modernisation de
l'action publique et aujourd'hui ça nous
touche de plein fouet y compris pour une
mission dite régalienne et parmi celles
qui comptent le plus avec notamment
l'éducation nationale et la justice
alors est ce que la police ait assez de
moyens pour fonctionner c'est la
question que nous sommes à déposer dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines on
écoute les réponses des habitants sont
des gens qui travaillent dans des
conditions assez
difficiles on ne donne pas les moyens de
travailler et puis ils passent leur
temps à faire de la paperasse qui est
pas normal de faire des enquêtes sur le
terrain bon on est bon pas mal souvent
ils traînent peut-être qu'ils auraient
besoin d'un peu plus de présence c'est
possible par les temps qui qu il ya
passé a service qui a un peu plus de
moyens qu'avant ils sont tous logés à la
même enseigne ils en ont les ans qu'ils
en aient ils font avec mais ceci dit je
pense pas que ce soit les tops non oui
moi je pense que ça va mais on peut
penser que la police manque de moyens
comme les autres services publics leur
manque un peu de moyens ce serait comme
ça a toujours fermé le soir et c'est
donc au cas où c'est des problèmes de
soirée dans les appels comme ils
s'arrêtent sincère ou de versailles ça
prend du temps pour qu'ils arrivent
les moyens je pense qu'ils sont
astreints peut installer
le commissariat de sa commune est
toujours fermée le soir il ya déjà des
des commissariats qu'on pas tout à fait
le même mode de fonctionnement que
d'autres tout à fait
après il ya des réponses très simple je
donne un exemple tout le monde
va comprendre quand les budgets sont
tombés pour la transition 2013 2014
c'est l'équivalent de 20 véhicules qui
ont été supprimés sur le département des
yvelines c'est colossal quand on sait
qu'il ya 19 circonscriptions à la base
voilà et puis d'autre part on a un
phénomène aussi qui est liée à la jury d
enfin vous coûter extrêmement judiciaire
en fait de l'ensemble des procédures que
nous traitons et elles sont si voulez de
plus en plus difficile à absorber d'un
point de vue administratif et on le voit
bien avec la réforme à venir de madame
taubira c'est à dire qu'il ya des
lourdeurs administratives ya de plus en
plus de place qui est laissée aux mises
en cause et peut à la victime et tout ça
mais ça doit être verrouillée et c'est
extrêmement difficile donc c'est autant
de temps et bien qu'ils ne sont pas
passés
en termes de prévention aux côtés des co
citoyens dans la rue la réforme pénale
on aurait bien aimé en discuter que
série de torres des syndicats ufap/unsa
du syndicat pénitentiaire mais n'a pas
pu arriver à temps pour cette pour cette
émission alors là je les guide à la
deuxième vague de réformes a été adopté
en conseil technique départementale donc
lundi vous avez voté sur certains points
wii d'autres points non elle va donc
s'appliquer ça très fort et septembre
tout à fait il ya eu la majorité qui
s'est dégagée ce comité technique
départemental
alors ben maintenant
l'idée ça va être ça va être
d'accompagner au mieux l'ensemble de nos
collègues et puis j'imagine que dans
beaucoup de services en fait on va sans
doute être confrontés à de nombreux
problèmes parce que par exemple on ne
sait pas comment elles vont être rédigé
les arrêtés d'affectation de nos
collègues alors c'est peut-être un petit
peu du nombrilisme mais ça c'est
important il faut les rassurer si on
fait une réforme surtout que nous on a
le set cette manie en fait de devoir se
plier à une multitude et le respect
qu'il a pour l'instant certains de vos
collègues ne savent pas où ils seront
affectés en septembre iliad il ya
effectivement des interrogations parce
qu'il va y avoir un système d'appel
d'offres pour en fait faire en sorte que
des postes soient comblées
et c'est donc là il y avait un vrai
travail d'un point de vue de la rh qui
va se dérouler dans les jours à venir
mais aussi d'un point de vue
organisationnel pour faire en sorte bien
en fait que tous ces déménagements se
fasse du mieux possible que ça veut dire
qu'on va l'accompagner puisqu'on est
forcé et contraint de le faire et vous
du syndicat alliance vous êtes forcé et
contraint puisque ça a été voté est-ce
que vous avez lancé d'autres actions
d'autres mouvements ah oui bien sûr
notre but depuis la première phase de re
de restructuration ça va peut-être déjà
systématiquement de dénoncer les
inepties et donc j'espère 4 ap on va
trouver des solutions parce que si
effectivement cela se fait au 1er
septembre alors même que mes collègues
n'auront plus de salle de repos ou
n'auront plus de salles pour faire du
sport quand on sait l'importance que
revêt lé sport dans notre profession est
fait qu'on va être en bonne santé y
compris jusqu'à l'âge de la retraite
pour courir après les voleurs je pense
très sincèrement que effectivement on va
forcément être amené de nouveau à mener
des actions
s'il le faut et si ça se fait pas dans
la concertation puisque ça a été quand
même ça difficile aussi d'avoir des
informations par le biais de la
direction départementale de la sécurité
publique et le directeur a quand même
donné un produit fini ficelez qu'on a
quasiment pas pu discuter et malgré ce
qui peut dire
c'est de la quiétude parce qu'il
certains savent qu'ils vont pas être
touché et c'est en fait tout ce qui a un
moment faut savez quand vous sortez
d'école ou que vous avez choisi une
circonscription c'est pas pour aller
bosser sur celle d'à côté il ya une
vraie logique par rapport à ça parce que
quand vous êtes
oui bien sûr et les collègues ont le
sens du service public et de
l'abnégation parce que je dire vu le
nombre de réformes on ne peut pas dire
que les policiers ne s'adaptent pas avec
le numéro d'identification porté sur la
tenue les dénonciations sur la
plateforme igpn la réforme de la garde à
vue à venir les différentes mesures
stigmatisantes qu'on a pu voir mises en
place dans le dernier code de
déontologie et les réformes
structurelles et opérationnelles locales
je pense que la déflation
elle est allée au quotidien il n'y a
aucun problème là dessus donc c'est
c'est pas une vue de l'esprit que dire
voilà on est devenus fous et on lutte
contre tous non c'est pas ça c'est qu'à
un moment il ya des choses qui se font
dans la précipitation et qui sont pas
logiques et je pense qu'on n'a pas bien
tirer les enseignements de la première
phase de restructuration notamment sur
les nuits les unités judiciaire dp
proximité qui en plus dans le cadre de
la phase 2 sont censés se développer
encore plus donc à suivre affaire à
suivre merci en tout cas loïc travers
d'être venu inscrire votre éclairage sur
cette réforme je veux dire de la police
pour pour résumer qui devrait se mettre
en place dans les yvelines en septembre
prochain merci à vous ces sept huit
sociétés maintenant terminé merci de
votre attention bonne soirée à vous
vous